WE'VE BUILT OURSELVES A BOAT.
WE HAVE PROVISIONED IT
FOR AT LEAST A FEW WEEKS AT SEA,
AND SOON WE'RE ABOUT TO HEAD OUT
INTO THE GREAT BLUE YONDER
TO TRY AND GET OURSELVES HOME.
Narrator: AND WHEN ADAM SAYS
THEY'VE PROVISIONED IT
FOR A FEW WEEKS,
HE'S NOT EXAGGERATING.
HERE'S WHAT WE'RE TAKING
ON OUR JOURNEY.
WE GOT ROPE,
WE GOT FISHING LINE,
WE GOT BAILERS, OARS, DUCT TAPE.
WE HAVE TARPS.
WE HAVE WATER BAGS, FOOD BAGS,
AND A FISHING SPEAR.
IF THAT DOESN'T HELP US MAKE IT,
WE WEREN'T MEANT TO.
Jamie: I THINK
WE'RE READY TO PUT IT IN, HUH?
LET'S CARRY IT DOWN.
ALL RIGHT.
Jamie: AT THIS POINT,
WE FOUND THAT DUCT TAPE
IS NOT A PERFECT SOLUTION
FOR ANYTHING.
[ GRUNTS ]
BUT WITH SOME CREATIVITY
IN A PINCH,
IT'S AN ADEQUATE SOLUTION
FOR JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING.
NOW, WHETHER IT'LL HOLD UP
TO A BOAT THAT HAS TO GET US
ACROSS THE OCEAN,
THERE'S ONLY ONE WAY
TO FIND OUT.
OKAY.
[ LAUGHS ]
AIM IT
TOWARDS THE WAVE.
WHOA!
Narrator:
AS THE GUYS CLAMBER IN...
AAH! AAH! WHOO!
...IT'S WORTH HIGHLIGHTING
THAT THE ONE THING
THEY DON'T HAVE IS A MAP.
[ LAUGHS ]
Jamie: IT'S WORKING!
OH, YEAH, BABY!
Narrator: LIKE REAL CASTAWAYS,
THEY'RE SIMPLY GOING TO PADDLE
UNTIL THEY FIND LAND OR SINK.
[ LAUGHS ]
PONTOON'S LOOKING GREAT.
Narrator: BUT WITH
THE BREAKING WAVES APPROACHING,
SINKING IS
A VERY REAL POSSIBILITY.
OH, NO!
HERE WE GO!
WHOA!
HEY, IT TOOK IT!
THERE'S
ANOTHER ONE COMING.
IT'S BIGGER.
UH-OH! DUDE!
OH [BLEEP]
HERE WE GO!
[ SHOUTS ]
[ BOTH LAUGHING ]
Adam:
THERE'S NO TWO WAYS ABOUT IT.
THOSE BREAKERS WERE INTENSE.
WHOA!
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
REMEMBER, WE'RE SITTING THERE
IN A CANOE MADE OF DUCT TAPE...
COME ON!
...PADDLING TOWARDS WAVES
THAT ARE LIKE 3 OR 4 FEET HIGHER
THAN THE PROW OF OUR BOAT.
WHOA!
YEAH!
THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT!
IT WAS ABSOLUTELY TERRIFYING,
BUT ONCE WE MADE IT PAST...
WHOO! [ LAUGHS ]
...TOTALLY KNEW WE HAD PASSED
ONE OF THE WORST HURDLES
WE COULD,
AND THE BOAT WAS GONNA BE OKAY.
Narrator: ADAM'S RIGHT.
HAVING SURVIVED THE BREAKERS...
HOW DOES SHE LOOK LIKE
SHE'S HOLDING UP IN THE WATER?
...THE MAIN QUESTION NOW...
LOOKING GREAT.
...IS WHETHER THE CANOE
WILL HOLD TOGETHER LONG ENOUGH
FOR THEM TO FIND CIVILIZATION.
MAN, IT IS HOT OUT HERE!
Jamie:
GIVEN THAT WE'RE IN THE OCEAN,
AND IT'S ABOUT 90 DEGREES,
WE'VE GOT BOTH IN SPADES,
BUT THE ONLY BAILING
I'M HAVING TO DO SO FAR...
ADAM, I'VE GOT
A LITTLE WATER BACK HERE.
...IS BECAUSE OF WATER THAT'S
BEING SPLASHED INTO THE BOAT
RATHER THAN ANY SORT OF LEAK.
ARE YOU SAYING
MY OAR TECHNIQUE SUCKS?
Narrator:
TWO HOURS IN AND WITH THEIR
ISLAND NOW A DISTANT MEMORY...
I CAN'T SEE
THE SHORE ANYMORE.
WE'RE IN OPEN WATER NOW.
...ADAM AND JAMIE
START RAIDING THEIR PROVISIONS.
FIRST WATER...
YOU WANT SOME?
...AND THEN FOOD.
THREE HOURS IN,
AND AN IMPROMPTU FISHING STOP...
THERE! RIGHT THERE!
AAH!
...IS ALL THAT SLOWED THEM DOWN.
[ GROANS ]
I THINK YOU MISSED IT.
AS THREE HOURS BECOMES FOUR...
DUDE, I'M GONNA TAKE
A LITTLE BREAK, OKAY?
...AND FOUR BECOMES FIVE...
LET'S JUST HOPE
WE'RE NOT PADDLING IN CIRCLES.
...LET'S PUT THIS
MARITIME MASTERPIECE IN CONTEXT.
ADAM AND JAMIE'S
YESTERDAY'S NEWS...
I'M KING OF THE WORLD!
WHOA!
...BROKE APART IN 20 MINUTES.
THEIR DUCT-TAPE DINGHY WAS
ON THE WATER NOT MUCH LONGER.
Jamie: TRY NOT TO PUT YOUR FEET
THROUGH THE BOTTOM.
AND THEIR ALCATRAZ ESCAPE RAFT
WAS AN ACCIDENT
WAITING TO HAPPEN.
I HAVE NO IDEA
WHERE WE ARE.
BUT THEIR DUCT-TAPE CANOE
HAS NOW BEEN IN THE OPEN OCEAN
FOR OVER HALF A DAY
AND IS STILL GOING STRONG.
THIS BOAT --
STRONGEST CASE YET
THAT DUCT TAPE IS
A FRICKIN' MIRACLE MATERIAL.
YEAH, THERE'S NO UNDERESTIMATING
THE POWER OF DUCT TAPE.
WITH NEITHER A LEAK NOR A TEAR,
YOU MIGHT SAY
IT'S BEEN PLAIN SAILING.
AND WHAT'S MORE...
DUDE!
LAND!
-I SEE IT.
[ LAUGHS ]
...AT LAST, AFTER CLOSE
TO SEVEN HOURS AT SEA,
LAND LOOMS LARGE
ON THE HORIZON.